[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le japon quelques
semaines après la démission de shinzo
abe le nouveau premier ministre vient de
prendre les rênes du pays proches
conseillers et bras droit d' abbey bio
shide suga hérite d'un bon nombre de
défis en interne comme dans les
relations avec les voisins du japon
alors quels sont les changements qui
secoue la vie politique japonaise
ces derniers temps le 28 août shinzo abe
annonce sa démission pour des raisons de
santé
la transition se fait vite le 16
septembre le parti dhabi qui détient la
majorité au parlement élit yoshi des
sugar à la tête du pays conservateur
jusqu au bout des ongles y promet de
poursuivre la politique de son
prédécesseur
à l'international le nouveau premier
ministre devra avant tout naviguer entre
les deux puissantes partenaires du japon
les états unis et la chine à peine
investi
il se dit prêt à poursuivre le
rapprochement avec pékin mais à
condition que cela n'affecte pas
l'amitié avec washington
parmi les autres défis qui attendent
suga les relations tendues avec la corée
du sud et bien sur l'épineux dossier des
îles kouriles
moins d'un mois après son arrivée au
pouvoir le nouveau premier ministre a
déjà désigné sa vision de l'amélioration
des relations avec les voisins du japon
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici un bref
portrait du nouveau premier ministre
japonais yoshi des sugar c'est le blitz
contrairement à ses prédécesseurs suga
est issu d'un milieu modeste et
populaire son père est cultivateur de
fraises dans la région d'akita sa mère
elle est enseignante
il gagne lui même sa vie dès le plus
jeune âge il finance seuls ses études à
tokyo en enchaînant des petits boulots
dans une usine de carton et travaille
comme vendeur dans un marché aux
poissons pour arrondir ses fins de mois
après ses études en droit il s'oriente
rapidement vers une carrière politique
et travaille comme assistant d'un élu de
yokohama puis devient à 38 ans
conseiller municipal de cette même ville
voisine de tokyo
neuf ans plus tard en 1996 il décroche
un siège de député à yokohama qu'il
détient d'ailleurs toujours à ce jour
sugar est ensuite promu ministre des
affaires intérieures et de la
communication sous le premier
gouvernement dab est de retour au
pouvoir en 2012
ab lui confie le poste de porte parole
et du secrétaire général du gouvernement
tout comme son prédécesseur yoshi des
soucaze promet de continuer une
politique d'inspiration conservatrice
mais très libérale sur l'économie une
nouvelle page s'ouvre dans l'histoire du
japon après huit années au pouvoir
shinzo abe annonce soudainement sa
démission pour des raisons de santé
le parti au pouvoir donne sa confiance à
yoshi des sugar pour succéder à l'ancien
premier ministre japonais proche
conseiller d'habré il hérite de son
prédéceseur d'un bon nombre de défis en
interne d'abord il devra avant tout
atténuer les conséquences d'une crise
économique qui a frappé le japon de
plein fouet suite à la pandémie de kovy
de 19 à l'international ensuite la
situation n'est pas moins compliqué car
le nouveau dirigeant japonais devra
naviguer entre deux puissants acteurs de
la scène internationale autour de tokyo
les états unis et la chine tout comme
son prédécesseur il donne la priorité
aux relations avec washington mais se
prononce en même temps
en faveur du rapprochement avec pékin
cette approche saura-t-elle viable
compte tenu de l'aggravation des
tensions entre la chine et les états
unis
l'autre sujet de réflexion que shinzo
abe lui a laissé c'est l'avenir des
relations nippo coréenne entachée par un
récent différend commercial
ici suga adopte une approche ferme pas
question de concessions côté japonais en
ce qui concerne la russie et le
règlement de la question des îles
kouriles le nouveau premier ministre
japonais semblent vouloir garder la même
approche que la précédente
administration
sauf que désormais un accord de paix
inclurait des roms indications sur
quatre îles kouriles et non pas deux un
appétit japonais qui risque de
compliquer les négociations avec moscou
quelle est donc la stratégie du nouveau
premier ministre à l'international qui
elles et le bilan de son prédécesseur
shinzo abe pourquoi les parlementaires
japonais ont-ils préféré suga aux autres
candidats pour répondre à ces questions
nous rejoignons art 90 à historien du
japon et directeur de recherche au cnrs
à l'institut d'asie orientale de lyon
monsieur nantas bonjour bonjour tout
d'abord pourquoi cette démission
inattendue dab et sa santé ou plutôt une
forte baisse de popularité la démission
du premier ministre à b est arrivé de
manière extrêmement surprenante elle a
pris de court l'ensemble des
spécialistes
néanmoins le premier ministre avait
souffrait d'une maladie à ses anciennes
qui l'avait déjà obligé à démissionner
lors de son premier passage à ses
fonctions de premier ministre en
2006-2007
c'est une maladie grave et très
douloureuse un type d'ulcères une recto
lite hémorragique
ça provoque déchirement au niveau de
l'intestin et des saignements dans le
ventre donc c'est une maladie
extrêmement difficile on peut penser
qu'ils avaient bénéficié de traitements
extrêmement puissant en espérant pouvoir
tenir jusqu'aux jeux olympiques qui
était un
un objectif anciens auxquels il tenait
tout particulièrement et finalement avec
le report des jo a priori à l'année 2000
vingt-et-une il aurait décidé d'arrêter
ne pouvant plus supporter ça si tu es si
sa condition il a débuté des nouveaux
apparemment médicaments à l'été mais
c'était déjà trop tard
on peut donc penser que la maladie même
si il est dans un contexte où il est
assez fait tiquer ils auraient à
s'expliquer on peut penser que la
maladie est la cause principale de son
départ
on dit que son successeur yoshi des
sugar est un abbé bis peut-être encore
plus conservateur que l'ancien premier
ministre japonais et tout d'accord avec
une telle perception alors le premier
ministre soudas il vient d'être nommé
semble se situer largement en continuité
avec le premier ministre avait il ya un
petit peu pour le moment difficile de le
qualifier de conservateurs l'avenir
répondra à cette question par contre il
est très certainement néolibérale au
niveau des politiques qu'ils proposent
il a immédiatement
lors de sa nomination mis en avant un
besoin de déréguler encore davantage
l'économie japonaise en réchauffant un
concept qui avait été employé dans les
années 1990
il sait quand noah la dérégulation
assouplissement des règlements par
ailleurs ce qui est intéressant pour
pour analyser la position du premier
ministre soudas qui vient à peine d'être
nommé
c'est la composition de son gouvernement
il se situe très largement en continuité
sur les ministères les plus importants
avec les gouvernements premier ministre
avait notamment on voit que le vice
premier ministre et ministre des les
poliques de l'économie
mais ce sont des économies il ya aussi
dans glee ce premier ministre reste
monsieur aso qui est sur une ligne
libérale très dur au niveau économique
donc on peut penser qu'il n'y aura
absolument aucun changement
le ministre des affaires étrangères
reste monsieur motegi
donc quelqu'un qui est très proche des
états unis on pourra y revenir dans la
seconde partie du programme et on trouve
au ministère de la défense et shinobu
ohno bourse qui se trouve être le frère
cadet de déchets nous aurons donc on a
une grande de la continuation du point
de vue des ministères principaux d'autre
part dans le cadre du temps du ministre
ad avait été soulignée après 2016
la relation intime entre les
gouvernements successifs du premier
ministre ab et l'organisation du pont de
kayes il a semblé du japon et est une
sorte de film tank conservateur et là
c'est un point qui va plutôt dans le
sens de la question puisque parmi les
vingt personnes qui composent le
gouvernement de sugar de monsieur soudas
quatorze personnes sont affiliés à la
nippone cailloux donc on a dans tous les
sens une bande continuation et un profil
sans doute conservateur très
certainement libéral sur le plan
économique en comparaison du mouvement
du premier ministre à vie merci beaucoup
monsieur nantes à nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
vous retrouverons en fin d'émission pour
plus de détails sur la question merci
coup de tonnerre politique au japon le
28 août le premier ministre shinzo abe
annonce sa démission lors d'une
conférence de presse à tokyo
j'ai décidé de ne plus rester à cette
place étant donné que je ne peux
répondre au mandat que m'a confié le
peuple avec assurance au pouvoir depuis
ab a battu les records de longévité en
tant que premier ministre japonais
expliquant à la presse son départ il
évoque des raisons de santé
plus précisément une maladie chronique
qui le poursuit depuis le début de sa
carrière une colite ulcéreuse
cependant la presse japonaise mans
sûr aussi un autre facteur important qui
aurait poussé à b vers la porte sa
baisse brutale de popularité selon un
sondage de l' agence de presse japonaise
kyodo le taux de confiance du
gouvernement a b n'était qu'à 36% en
août un des plus bas niveaux depuis son
arrivée au pouvoir
parmi les causes la gestion de bien sûr
de la crise sanitaire qui a lourdement
frappé l'économie du pays selon les
chiffres officiels le trimestre d'avril
à juin s'est caractérisée par une
contraction de 7 8% du pib par rapport
au trimestre précédent
le 14 septembre yoshi des sugar proches
conseillers et bras droit de chine aux
abbés remporte l'élection du chef du
parti libéral démocrate et devient son
successeur il recueille 377 vote sur 534
dépassant largement ses deux adversaires
fumio kishida ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères et shigeru ishiba
ancien ministre de la défense dans son
discours de victoire suga promet de
s'inscrire dans la continuité de la
ligne politique du gouvernement sortant
or pour suivre la voie de son
prédécesseur ne sera pas une chose aisée
c'est surtout vrai pour la politique
étrangère ou ab jouer l'équilibriste
entre les deux puissants partenaires du
japon les états unis et la chine
il faut dire que washington est le
principal allié stratégique de tokyo
dans le cadre du traité bilatéral sur la
sécurité est signée il ya 60 ans le
japon accueille deux base américaine sur
l'île d'okinawa et mènent régulièrement
les exercices militaires conjointes avec
la marine américaine
côté commercial la coopération est tout
aussi forte
les etats unis sont le deuxième
partenaire commercial du japon est celui
ci est aussi le principal détenteur
d'obligations souveraines américaines
ardent défenseur d'une alliance
américano-japonaise le premier ministre
sortant shinzo abe prôné en même temps
une diversification des partenaires
diplomatiques
une politique qui a eu comme résultat un
certain dégel des relations avec par
exemple la chine adversaire stratégique
du japon mais
ici pas doaks allemand l'un de ses
partenaires commerciaux les plus
importants
en effet le volume de leurs échanges
s'est élevé à 310 milliards de dollars
en 2019
la même année les investissements
directs du japon en chine ont atteint un
niveau historique de 14,4 milliards de
dollars profitant de la main d'oeuvre
bon marché de la stabilité politique
plus de vingt mille entreprises
japonaises ont une présence permanente
en chine
pourtant l'année dernière la moitié de
ces entreprises constatent une baisse
notable de leur chiffre d'affaires la
cause en est la preuve bataille
commerciale que se livrent les états
unis et la chine afin de minimiser les
effets néfastes pour son économie le
japon évite de prendre parti et
souhaitent à tout prix conserver
l'équilibré d'un côté tokyo conclu en
2019 un accord commercial avec
washington selon ses termes
le japon doit diminuer les tarifs
douaniers à hauteur de 7 milliards de
dollars pour les biens agricoles
américains en retour washington consent
à baisser les droits de douane sur un
certain nombre de biens agricoles
japonais tels que le thé vert et la
sauce soja
de leur côté tokyo pékin et séoul
accélèrent les négociations sur un
accord de libre-échange censé effacer
les barrières douanières entre leurs
marchés
ces négociations vont-elles finalement
aboutir sachant que le nouveau premier
ministre japonais donne la priorité aux
relations avec washington alors que la
situation autour du japon devient de
plus en plus difficile
je développerai mon action politique
dans le cadre de l'alliance entre le
japon et des etats unis
néanmoins en prônant l'amitié avec
washington le nouveau premier ministre
japonais n'oublie pas non plus le
processus de réconciliation avec pékin
qu'il entend continuer je souhaite
également établir des relations stables
avec les pays voisins notamment avec la
chine et la russie
alors le rapprochement sino japonais
va-t-il se poursuivre sous le
gouvernement de sugar quels sont les
autres défis qui se dessine devant le
nouveau premier ministre à
l'international enfin quel héritage le
gouvernement sortant les styles à zoug a
la réponse
après la pause
[Musique]
la transition vient d'avoir lieu après
huit ans au pouvoir je suis aux abbés
laisse finalement son poste à yoshi des
sugar secrétaire en chef du gouvernement
sortant ce dernier promet de poursuivre
les efforts de son prédécesseur qui a
renforcé le poids du japon à
l'international et transformer
l'économie du pays héritier d'une grande
famille de politiciens shinzo abe fait
ses premiers pas en politique au début
des années 80 il commence d'abord en
tant que secrétaire particulier auprès
de son père shintaro ab alors ministre
des affaires étrangères deux ans après
la mort de ce dernier en 1993 shinzo abe
est élu député au parlement dès lors
shinzo abe gravi les échelons il devient
entre 2000 et 2003 secrétaire en chef dé
cabinet d premier ministre yoshiro mori
et yoni shiro koizumi
en 2003 il prend la tête du parti
libéral-démocrate fondée par son grand
père et ex premier ministre
nobuo kikuchi à cette époque ce parti
domine la scène politique nippone depuis
1955 en 2006 ab se hisse au sommet de
l'état à 52 ans il devient le plus jeune
premier ministre du pays laissant
espérer une rupture dans le monde
politique nippon
pourtant son mandat est un échec marquée
par une succession de scandales
politiques et financiers les résultats
ne se font pas attendre puisqu'il perd
les élections législatives de 2007
face à cet échec cuisant une réputation
écornée et des ennuis de santé ab
démissionne en 2007
s'ensuit alors une période d'instabilité
politique au japon un nouveau premier
ministre
tous les ans entre 2006 et 2012
cependant la valse des têtes s'arrête
bientôt
après une traversée du désert de près de
5 ans shinzo abe revient sur le devant
de la scène politique assurant qu'il
compte bien cette fois ci est restée en
il retrouve le fauteuil de premier
ministre qu'il conserve jusqu'en 2020
lors de ses mandats successifs
ab s'attache à sortir le pays de la
période de déflation qui ronge le pays
depuis près de deux décennies son
programme économique ambitieux se résume
en trois points
un assouplissement monétaire une relance
budgétaire et des réformes structurelles
les résultats sont pourtant mitigés au
cours de ses trois mandats
entre 2012 et 2020 la croissance
annuelle moyenne atteint 1,2 pour cent
loin des 2% initialement prévu sur le
plan diplomatique shinzo abe n'a eu de
cesse de repositionner le japon comme un
acteur important tant sur la scène
régionale qu'internationale
ab a voulu avant tout rompre avec la
politique étrangère de ses prédécesseurs
longtemps qualifié de suivi et multiplie
les partenariats dans les domaines tant
de la défense que du commerce
face à la montée en puissance de la
chine shinzo abe renforce l'ayant
sécuritaire avec les états unis lui
achetant des systèmes de défense
antimissile et avions de chasse durant
son mandat avait augmente
considérablement le budget de la défense
il s'élève aujourd'hui à 47 milliards de
dollars soit le huitième budget
militaire au monde
outre l'aspect sécuritaire shinzo abe il
souhaite développer des liens
commerciaux dans la région
le japon sim le partenariat
transpacifique destinée à faire
contrepoids à la chine etc nouvelle
route de la soie
au total une dizaine de pays dont le
canada l'australie le vietnam et
singapour nous rejoint même avec son
rival la chine shinzo abe renforce les
liens économiques
pourtant certaines questions comme le
contentieux territorial des îles
kouriles avec la russie reste encore
irrésolu la fin de son mandat est aussi
assombri par la guerre commerciale avec
la corée du sud toujours en cours le
bilan de shinzo abe est certes imposant
mais il laisse à yoshi des souks à
plusieurs problèmes en suspens parmi eux
et les relations tumultueuses avec la
corée du sud
remontant au passé colonial ces tensions
déborde dans le domaine commercial et
militaire
le premier sujet de crispation au reste
le travail forcé des coréens à l'époque
de la colonisation japonaise pour le
japon l'accord ni pau sud coréen de 1965
à refermer cette plaie malgré tout elle
va refaire parler d'elle en 2018 lorsque
la cour suprême sud-coréenne rend un
jugement qui enflamme
les relations entre séoul et tokyo en
effet celle ci ordonne à un géant de la
sidérurgie japonaise de compenser
financièrement quatre sud coréens qui
avaient été contraints de travailler
dans ses aciéries entre 1941 et 1943
c'est le début de l' escalade
diplomatique tokyo durci d'abord sa
politique d'exportations avec la
péninsule et retire ensuite séoul de sa
liste de partenaires de confiance
le japon restreint en plus l'exportation
vers la corée du sud de matériaux clés
pour la production de puces et de
smartphones ce qui frappe au coeur les
entreprises de high tech
seoul riposte par le boycott de produits
japonais et menaces d'abroger l'accord
de partage de renseignements avec tokyo
le dernier volet de la crise date de
juillet dernier
les sociétés japonaises qu'ils
refuseraient de payer des compensations
aux travailleurs forcés chute coréen
risque maintenant d'être privés de leurs
actifs et ce n'est pas tout un autre
souvenir du passé gangrène toujours les
relations bilatérales
ce sont les femmes de réconfort coréenne
en fait esclave sexuelle au service de
colomb japonais en 2015 tokyo accepte de
verser 9 milliards de dollars à la
fondation coréenne des deux anciennes
femmes de réconfort de plus
shinzo abe leur présente ses excuses
personnelles pourtant cet accord est
rompu par le nouveau président de la
république de corée moudjahidine qui
arrivent au pouvoir en 2017
il rejette l'idée de compensation et
exige des excuses officielles de la part
du japon en tant qu'etat ce que tokyo
refuse de faire mais l'arrivée au
pouvoir de yoshi des sugar peut-elle
changer la donne
la chine et la corée du sud sont nos
voisins et malgré les
problèmes difficiles que nous avons
j'entends adopté une ligne qui nous
permettra de maintenir les échanges et
développer des relations stratégiques
avec les deux plutôt que de choisir l'un
ou l'autre un discours plutôt bien reçue
à séoul
dans sa lettre de félicitations à
yoshihide suga le président sud coréen
se dit prêt à une rencontre à tout
moment pour résoudre les différends
notre gouvernement projette de coopérer
activement avec le premier ministre sous
gars et le nouveau cabinet surmontant
ainsi avec sagesse les problèmes liés à
l'histoire et renforçant la coopération
en matière d'économie de culture et des
échanges entre les personnes de manière
mutuellement bénéfique
cependant on est loin d'en avoir fini
avec les coups de théâtre et les
incidents diplomatiques car tokyo contre
toute attente a accueilli avec froideur
la main tendue de la diplomatie sud
coréenne
et ce n'est pas tout désormais elle
accuse même séoul de violer la loi
internationale en exigeant des
réparations aux entreprises japonaises
l'espoir de normalisation est il
définitivement enterré c'est peut-être
aussi pour cela que yoshi des sugar
reste prudent quant à l'avenir d'un
autre processus de paix celui des
relations avec la russie
en effet moscou et tokyo n'ont jamais
conclu de traité de paix après la
seconde guerre mondiale le point
d'achoppement étant le problème de
l'appartenance de quatre îles de
l'archipel des kouriles itouroup
kounachir shikotan et habomai et sont
aujourd'hui sous administration russe
mais sont revendiquées par le japon
riche en minerais et en métaux rares aux
réserves immenses de poissons cgil ont
aussi une importance stratégique leur
contrôle ouvre d'abord un accès
permanent à l'océan pacifique pour la
marine russe
grâce au détroit qui sépare kounachir
dit au groupe et qui ne gèle pas en
hiver et ensuite le contrôle de ce même
des 3 permet de protéger la mère russe
deux coaches d'une incursion sous
marines étrangères stratégique pour la
russie est nécessaire pour un japon au
territoire limité ces îles sont un
problème sur lequel les deux parties
reste intransigeante et pourtant shinzo
abe
n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour faire
avancer sa proposition de règlement il a
rencontré vladimir poutine plus souvent
que n'importe quel dirigeant mondial
27 fois l'ancien dirigeant japonais à
continuer les pourparlers même après
l'exclusion de la russie du g20 shinzo
abe a toujours mis en avant sa relation
personnelle avec la dîmière poutine
selon ses propres paroles
les deux dirigeants ont mangé un minot
de sel ensemble en 2018
poutine propose même au japon de
conclure un traité de paix sans
conditions préalables
cette initiative à relancer l'effort de
réconciliation sur la base de la
déclaration russo japonaises de 1956
selon ce texte les deux parties
s'engageraient à diviser les il est
accordé deux d'entre elles
chico temps et habomai au japon pourtant
c'était l'an n'a pas eu le temps
d'aboutir
pour mieux comprendre ce qu'attend le
japon dans l'année à venir
nous rejoignons à nouveau à 90 à
historien du japon et directeur de
recherche au cnrs à l'institut d'asie
orientale de lyon
monsieur dans ta parlons maintenant
géopolitique shinzo abe a entrepris une
tentative de diversifier ses partenaires
comment voyez-vous l'avenir des
relations entre tokyo et washington
l'avenir des relations entre le japon et
les états unis sera probablement
exactement à l'identique de ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
le nouveau premier ministre monsieur
sugar a rappelé qu'il avait assisté en
tant que secrétaire général du
gouvernement japonais c'est à dire une
forme de porte parole a quasiment
l'intégralité dé discuter rendez-vous
les discussions des entretiens entre le
premier ministre
ab et le président des états unis et
qu'il est donc très proche de ses
partenaires américain et surtout le
nouveau ministre des affaires étrangères
est le même que le précédent ne surgit
motegi
il vient des réseaux des japonais proche
des états unis au départ
en politicien de carrière mais quelqu'un
qui a réussi à faire sa place militaire
étrangère et qui est donc sur une ligne
rapprochement il continue entre le japon
et les etats-unis par ailleurs vous
entre le candidat à la présidence du
parti libéral-démocrate donc pour
pouvoir devenir ensuite premier ministre
un ancien notamment monsieur ici bas il
s'est opposé sur certains points du
sugar ou bien monsieur kishida on se
sont accordés avec le premier ministre
souvent sur la nécessité du maintien et
des bases militaires américaines au
japon
donc il ya on peut considérer qu'il ya
un accord total entre les diverses
factions du parti libéral démocrate et
que le premier ministre sous dalle est
soutenu sur ce point
donc je pense que dans l'île de
renforcement de la rupture qu'il s'agit
et quid de la chine pour le japon c'est
plutôt un partenaire dans la région où
un adversaire ou les deux le chine la
république populaire de chine est
évidemment un partenaire pour le chapon
et on ne peut que l'espérer que les
liens se renforcent et les tensions
s'apaisent
néanmoins sur la question des relations
avec la chine populaire la question de
la relation entre le japon et les
etats-unis est déterminante
comme vous le savez les tensions entre
la chine populaire
les états unis vont croissantes pour
diverses raisons après notamment à
l'origine des tensions commerciales qui
ça va bien au-delà aujourd'hui et le
japon risque de se retrouver en manque
des zones y ait de sa relation avec les
états unis
d'autre part un autre point important
est la question de taiwan
donc la non officiel et république de
chine la plaie vue l'elysée ancien il
leur inculque populaire de chine sur
taïwan ont commencé à hockey des
crispations en europe
elles sont également un des facteurs à
l'origine des tensions entre les
etats-unis et la république populaire de
chine le japon a une position ambiguë
néanmoins lors des funérailles du
président lincoln guey y avait des
paiements dans les années 90 au mois
d'août
l'ancien premier ministre
di bello avait assisté donc à taïwan de
ses funérailles avait été porteur d'une
lettre de l'ancien premier ministre
ab disque qui notifie à la présidence
taiwanaise l'importance des liens entre
le japon et taïwan non c'est cette pose
cette question de la position du japon
sur la question taïwanaise et de sa
proximité qui les unit vont évidemment
jouer en détention contre la chine merci
beaucoup à 90 ha je rappelle vous êtes
historien du japon et directeur de
recherche au cnrs à l'institut d'asie
orientale de lyon merci d'avoir apporté
votre éclairage dans cette émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]